이상 빌사남의 노크 있습니다 아 저
안녕하고 빌사남의 노크 안녕하세요
빌사남의 노크 김현수입니다 저희 첫
게스트 궁금하시죠 빌사남의 영인 리치
칠한 김영준
계사
안녕하세요 안녕하세요 영가 만나는
리치한 사람들의 영인 리치 김영
중개사입니다 빌사남의 노크는
구독자분들의 의견을 받아서 고민을
해결해 드리는 콘텐츠인데 바로 사연을
만나보겠습니다 저희 영 중계사 님이
한번 읽어주세요 안녕하세요 30대 초
올해 6월 결혼을 앞둔 신혼
부부입니다 신혼 부부면 반드시
준비해야 될게 너무 많잖아요 이제
서울에서 신혼집을 구하려고 하는데
요즘 전세사기 때문에 이슈들이 너무
많잖아요 유튜브만 보더라도 전세사기
당했다 전세사기 피해자 이런 식으로
막 올라오는데 보면 너무 무서워요
그래서 전문가인 공인중개사들에게
여쭤보고 싶은데요 전 세작이 안당하는
방법 그리고 사기를 당했을 때 대처
방법 제발 꼭 제발 알려 주세요
아무래도 요즘에 좀 전 세사이
많잖아요 전세사기 좀 주의해야 될
것들 이런 거를 좀 얘기 나누면 좋을
것 같은데 영 중계사 님이 보셨던
이런 사례가 혹시 있으실까요 제가
주변에서 사례는 본 적은 없고요 저도
뉴스를 통해서 이제 전세 사기에 대한
이슈를 많이 접하다 보니까 가장 큰
문제가 내가 소유자가 아닌데 소
소유자인 척해서 계약을 해서이
계약금을 치한 거 그런 것들이 있는
거 같고 두 번째는 또 어떤 것들이
있을까요 이중 계약 이중 계약 예
나한텐 전세 계약하고 다른 사람한테
월세 계약하고 아 그런 경우도 있을
수 있죠 아 근데 이게 상당히 많아요
정말로 황당한 경우였는데 그래서 제가
최근에 봤던 분도 세무사 분이었는데
이렇게 이중 계약이 된 거예요 그래서
제 얘기 듣고 되게
놀라셔요 막 이렇게 하셨던 경우도
있는데 이중 계약도 되게 많은 거
같아요 어 그런 경우 진짜 당황스럽게
이걸 예방하려면 어떤 식으로 해야
될까요 그러니까 이제 가장 큰게
이중계약을 했을 때 집 주인분 확인을
안 한 거죠 집 주인분은 월세 계약한
걸로 알고 있는데 부동산이 이제 전세
계약을 해놓고 전세금을 탈취한
사건이죠 그렇죠 이런 이중 계약
사건도 되게 많이 있었던 거 같습니다
그리고 또 다른 이중계약 사례는
집주인이이 사람한테도 전세 계약을
받아 놓고 다른 사람한테도 또
전세계약을 또 받은 경우도 있고
그다음에 제가 알기로는 가장 큰 거는
매매가 전세가 갭이 너 적게 벌어져
있을 때 갭투자를 해 놨다가 전세금을
못 돌려줘서 전세 사기가 되는 경우도
있다고 많이 들었습니다 제가 봤을
때는 메가에 한 60% 넘어도 되게
리스크가 크다라고 생각하거든요 그
요즘에 경매 낙찰 잘 안 되고 그래서
실제로 경매 사이트 들어가 보면
전세사기 당한 매물이 엄청 많아요
반드시 이렇게 전세 계약할 때 그
집에 시세 요즘에 많이 나와 있잖아요
디스코 부동산이라는 뭐 밸류맵
이라든지 뭐 이런 실거래가 공개
사이트들이 많아서 시세를 확인하고 고
전세 계약을 하시면은 그래도 안전할
것 같습니다 그리고 또 사례 중에
제가 봤던 거 중에 신탁 소유가
있어요 신탁 보면은 대출금이 안 나와
있거든요 등기사항 전무 증명서에 근데
사실 이렇게 신탁 계약을 하려면 신탁
원부를 봐야 돼요 맞습니다 예 근데
신탁 원부를 안 보고 계약하시는
분들도 많고 신탁사의 동의도
필요하거든요 그런 것까지 안 하고
등기부 깨끗하네 그냥 해가지고 이체
했다가 이제 문제가 되는 경우가 되게
많거든요 이런 것들은 그 등기부 보면
갑구에 신탁사로 넘어가게 되면
신탁사가 적혀 있거든요 집중이라고
말하는 분과 계약을 하면 안 되고
신탁사와 계약을 그죠 그뭐 탁사랑
하더라도 신탁사의 동의도 받아야 되고
신탁 원부 등기소 가면 뗄 수 있는데
거기에 이제 채무 금액도 나와
있거든요 그래서 채무 금액이 너무
많다라고 하면은 그런 건 좀 들어가면
되게 리스크가 있지 않나 이렇게
생각합니다 그리고 저 같은 경우에는
또 권해드리는게 구글링을 좀 해보셨
좋겠어요 딱 쉽게 생각하면 전세금을
주 게 돈 빌려주는 거예요 그래서 돈
빌려줬는데이 사람이 진짜 돈 갚을
능력이 되는지 그런 걸 확인해야
되는데 요즘에는 구글링 하면은 전세이
사기꾼들의 그 명상이 있어요 그거를
저도 좀 배워야겠네요 저도 구글링하는
법을 좀 배워야겠습니다 예 그래서 저
그 뭐야 최근에 이제 지인분이 사기
당하셔야 제 좀 알아봐 셨는데 이게
면간 올라와 있더라고요 사기꾼 이렇게
해가지고 얼굴도 나와 있는데 여러분들
전세에 들어가실 때 집주인분 한번 좀
구글링해서 검색해 보시면 그 명단에
도 들어갈 수도 있으니까 그런 것도
확인해 보시면 좋을 것 같습니다
그다음에 또 보증보험 가입하는 거 좀
어떻게 생각하세요 보증보험은 저는
무조건 가입 된다고 생각하고 저는
전세 계약할 때 보증보험이 가입이 안
되면 그냥 계약은 해제한다는 문구
넣어 가지고 안 되면 사실 안
들어가는게 맞아요 그런 조항들도 좀
넣어서 전세 계약을 하는 거를 좀
권해드리고 많은 분들이 보증금을 못
돌려받고 이제 어떻게 해야 되냐라는
분들이 되게 많거든요 그럼 어떻게
해야 될까요 1번 경찰에 신고를
한다 2번네 법률적 자문을 구한다
그리고 이제 개인적으로 할 수 있는
거는 임차권 등기 명령이나 계속 안
나가고 버티기 계획을 하고 그냥
기업적 사기를 치는 거는 사실은 당할
수밖에 없다고 생각합니다 저희가
어찌됐든 임차권 등기 명령하기
전까지는 전입 신고도 돼 있어야 되고
건물을 점유하고 있어야 되거든요
그래야지 대항력이 있는데 보통 분들은
이제 전세금 안 빼주는데 이제 이사갈
곳이 생겨 가지고 거기로 전입을 빼는
순간 어떻게 되냐면 대항력이 없어져요
쉽게 설명드리면 은행 창고에 갔는데
번호표를 뽑을 거 아니에요 그럼 다시
그냥 없어진 거예요 그래서 여러분들
만약에 전세금 못 돌려 받았다라고
하면은 절대 다른 데다가 전입 하시면
안 되고 그리고 짐도 빼시면 안
됩니다 돈 받을 때까지 그냥 있어야
돼 근데 이제 피이 못할 사정으로
이제 나가게 된다고 하면 꼭 임차권
등기 명령을 꼭 하고 나가시면 그리고
이제 더 안전한 거는 사실 전세 할
때 전세권 설정 등기를 하는게 제일
안전할 거 같아요 맞습니다 물론 이제
이제 비용이 들어가긴 하지만 전세권
설정 등기 돼 있으면 전세금 못
받으면 경매 신청할 수 있거든요 그런
걸 통해서도 할 수 있기 때문에
사전에 전입 신고나 확정 일자만
받는게 아니라 나중에 이제 이런
조치까지 하면 뭐 전세금을 좀
안전하게 지킬 수 있지 않을까 중개사
같은 경우에는 일반적으로 이렇게 실장
직함을 가지고 계신 분들이 대부분
보면 보조원들이 많거든요 자격증이
없는 분들이죠 그렇죠 대부분이죠
중개사 같은 경우에는 자격증을
잃어버릴 수도 있고 문제가 될 수
있는 경우도 있어서 보통 이제 계약할
때 신경을 그래도 많이 쓰거든요 근데
보조원 분들은 사실 이을게 없어요
퇴사하면 그만 그렇죠 지금 나한테
집을 보여줬던 사람이 중개 산지도
확인하는게 중요한 거 같습니다 중개업
조회하고 치시면이 사람이 자격증이
있는지 없는지 만약에 이제 거기
등록이 안 돼 있다라고 하면은이
사람은 사실 위험한 사람이죠 그렇죠
무자격자가 이제 중계를 하는 꼴리
그죠 정식적으로 등록이 돼 있는
업체고 돼 있는 사람인지도 확인하면
좋 거 습니다 맞습니다 그리고 이제
저희가 계약을 하고 나면 부동산 중계
업소에서 보증 보험 증서를 전달해
주는 주거든요 그것도 꼭 챙기셔서
한번 확인을 해 보셔야 될 것
같습니다네 그래서 오늘 좀 정리를
해보자면 우리가 첫 번째 계약 전에
확인해야 될 거 내가 들어가려는 집과
등기부 등본을 뛰었을 때 표제부에 그
주소가 일치하는지 확인한다 2번 갑구
갑구에는 이제 소유자에 대한 정보가
나와 있는데 내가 계약하려는 사람이
집 주인인지 갑구에 나와 있는 정보를
가지고 확인을 하시고요 세 번째가
을구 거 같아요 을구에는대 를 얼마나
받았는지 등이 나와 있는데 이거를
통해서 나의 자산을 좀 지킬 수
있는지 위험성 등을 좀 판단해서
계약을 좀 진행하시면 좋을 것
같습니다 메가랑 전세 금이랑 확인을
해야 되고 그게 한 뭐 60%
이상이다 하면 조심할 필요가 있다
그거를 좀 방어하는 식단은 보증
보험에 가입하시거나 전세권 설정을
하시거나 협상을 해보시면 좋을 것
같아요 그다음에 구글링을
꼭 아니 돈 빌려주는데 확인해야죠 아
그죠 구글링 저도 꼭 배우도록
하겠습니다 그리고 이제 계약 이후에
만약 전 금 못 받았다 짐 빼지
마시고 확정일자를 꼭 받아 놓으시고
점유를 지키시고 불가피하게 빼야
된다라고 하면 자권 어 등기 신청을
꼭 하시면 좋을 거 같고 소중한 자기
전재산이 될 수도 있는 전세금을 꼭
지킬 수 있게 오늘은 우리 빌사남의
제일 잘생기신 제일 잘생기신 김영
중개사님 모시고 좀 이야기를
나눠봤는데 여러분들 혹시 뭐
궁금해하시는 부분이 있다라고 하면
댓글로 남겨 주시거나 아니면메일로
보내 주시면 하연을 통해서 앞으로 좀
컨텐츠 제작하게 많이 도움이 될 거
같으니까 많이 많이 남겨 주시면 좋을
것 같습니다 그럼 오늘 여기까지
하겠습니다 이상 빌사남의 노크
있습니다 안녕하고네 이상 빌사남의
노크 있습니다 안녕 안녕